[Music]
Peter thanks for joining spectator TV
pleasure you spent some time in prison
lately tell us about that well it's very
unpleasant uh but I volunteered for it
so I can't complain if you can't take a
joke you shouldn't have joined Channel 4
came to me and said would I take part in
a reality experiment in as near as could
possibly be recreated to a a real prison
they' hired a number of former actual
prisoners and a number of actual retired
prison officers and they also hired a
recently decommissioned prison in
chisbury
and they proposed to put us all together
those people and about seven minor
celebrities such as I am uh in these
circumstances and film us all the time
see what happened see how we took it and
I've been quite uh trenchant about
prisons in my life and I still hold
quite strong opinions about them and I
thought it would be cowardly of me to
say no so I said yes a lot of people put
up with it for a whole week I would have
put up with it for a week if i' been
asked but they they kept me out until
the the final four days and that I have
to tell you was quite enough I was very
pleased when it was over there was
nother were moments of laughter and uh
what you might call bonding and and
quite emotional moments but it was never
at any stage of pleasure and never
something that you wanted to last any
longer than it did to go back to the
beginning when Channel 4 approached you
about this you must have had some
reservations what made your principal so
to speak uh Trump the reservations you
might have had well I didn't really I in
a long life I've learned that
opportunities often come to you in un
alluring ways uh and this is very un you
might as well take them quite often
things which which appear on your Ang to
begin with Journeys that you might or
might not undertake places you might or
might not go to uh it's almost always
worth saying yes so probably I was the
least likely person to have misgivings
about it you said you spent four days in
shubber prison how real did this
simulation feel often very real uh the
building is as it would be and they' be
very carefully made it as as as as like
the real thing as possible the officers
behaved as far as possible as they would
have done and the prisoners I think in
in M it rather nobly because they saw it
as a way of of making some restitution
for what they' done these are all former
prisoners who stopped being criminals I
really entered into the spirit of it
they gave us as much as possible what we
would have got if it had been real now
we knew that it was most unlikely that
any serious violence would take place uh
we knew other characteristics of real
prison weren't there we also knew that
ultimately we could get out you could
you could breast the chicken switch and
someone would come and take you away for
but it was was very dis very much
discouraged and you were told it would
it would be very unwelcome I don't think
anybody actually did that but you knew
ultimately but in fact you quite quickly
forgot once you were in there that it
was it was possible to get out you
became very convinced you were there by
compulsion you'd lost all power over
your life and the architecture the power
of architecture was one of the most
underestimated Arts I always go on about
it but I have to say being in a
Victorian prison built with with the
purpose
of impressing on the convicted prisoner
that he has done wrong uh is quite is
quite an experience the very bricks are
talking to you the shape of the archway
of the door the tunnel shape of the cell
the high window with a view of nothing
except a chimney and the famous little
tent of blue the prisoners call the sky
all that does have an impact on you and
the clanging of heavy iron and the stamp
of of booted feet on cast iron Landings
it it comes home to you and and makes
you behave and feel differently quite
lonely uh and quite downcast you
mentioned in your piece that the
experience felt almost religious was
part of that the setting I think yes I
think but I think any any any serious uh
experience of of unpleasantness of
solitude of self-doubt uh and of fear
because there was some fear involved in
it I think it turns the Mind towards God
if there's any room in your mind for God
it's all these things will turn your
mind towards him I wanted to ask if you
were afraid were you consistently afraid
were there specific moments were you the
moments when I was afraid I these were
people who had obviously been capable in
their past lives of great violence I
didn't know who they were we got a very
sketchy introduction to who they were
they looked in many cases quite
frightening there were occasions when I
I'm my very voice annoys people uh and
it does I have to be as I've written in
the article I have to be careful on
public transport later night speaking as
I do my manner the things that I say
they annoy people and I wasn't totally
sure I don't want to cast any slur on
anybody uh because in fact was I got a
lot of generosity from the forign
prisoners but at the beginning of it I
really wasn't sure where I stood with
him and I thought it was perfectly
possible I might have an accident on the
stairs well I'm sure respect TV Watchers
will be delighted to be listening to you
Peter um I want to talk about one
session where you spoke with an
ex-convict about drugs and addiction
tell our viewers what happened in that
very confrontational session well I
didn't I I have two very unpopular
opinions one that addiction just two
addiction doesn't exist no I have lots
but on this subject two particularly
unpopular ones one of the addiction
doesn't exist which doesn't uh it's it's
an attempt to abolish free will the
whole the whole use of the term in in
the way that it is used in the English
language which is part from I else
extremely variable and the other is that
marijuana is not a soft and safe drug
that anybody can take and without harm
but it is in fact probably the most
dangerous of all the drugs I decided I
didn't want to because I know it can get
very boring I didn't want to have a
rabit Addiction in prison as I was sure
that the the the idea that that there
was there is no real free will that
we're not really responsible for actions
would be pretty popular among as
prisoners and not one I'd be I'd have an
easy time dissuading them but on the
other hand when people started talking
about marijuana as a soft drug I thought
here I am this may go on to television I
can't sit here it would be cardly to sit
here and keep my mouth shut so I said
that what I think that it's an
incredibly Dangerous Drug and the number
of people became extremely angry with
immensely strong and it also destroys
the lives of children I can focus on
things I'm totally focused on things on
weed what you talking how did it end
well it ended with them storming out on
the in that scene but afterwards for for
more than a few hours I was getting
pretty nasty looks from some of the
people
involved Peter I don't know if you'll
remember this this was years ago I was
still in Think Tank world you and I
exchanged some emails about the gender
pay Gap yes I do remember and I remember
after almost every email you'd sign off
your name and PS you're still wrong
about drugs just so I remember just so I
was clear that we didn't agree on it
it's it's it's a the the the whole
attitude of of intelligent educated
people towards drugs in our society is
an extraordinary thing and it's done as
far I an enormous amount of harm so I
keep at it where I see any signs of Hope
if I think you should be you should be
flattered that I thought you were worth
the effort well clear you made very
clear on on only on particular topics
we'll have that debate another time sure
um my last question to you Peter is
whether or not your views on British
prisons have changed since no because
they're not what people think they are
I've never been lock people up for the
rest of their lives bread and water uh
flogging person I don't think there's
any point in that I think long prison
senten is a futile they destroy the
souls of those who subject you to them
I've seen inside quite a lot of prisons
and having done that you can't I think
really be human and believe that sending
people to prison for very long periods
of time is normally Justified obviously
there are cases where people have simply
be kept off the streets but but I
personally would rather be deaded uh
than spend 25 years in a in a in a
prison and that that's just an
expression of absolute opinion from what
I've seen of them so I'm not in favor of
that I think prisons should be
austere uh I think they should involve a
lot of hard work and I think that they
should be full of the power of the state
the problem with prisons is that they're
tough in the wrong way way uh they're
not austere they're squalid uh they're
chaotic despite the efforts of the
hugely outnumbered prison offices whose
whose role in this is so often
completely underestimated and who and
who keep things from becoming totally un
civilized in a way which ought to be
more valued but they are chaotic uh they
are increasingly under the control of
the inmates they're full of drugs and
they're full of suicide and they're full
of uh of completely uncontrol violence
and therefore there is no in the place
where the law sends people there is no
rule of law in fact there is no rule of
authority and so they're completely
unfit for the for the job they're
supposed to do so I would have them say
back under the control of the
authorities places Punishment Due
punishment of responsible persons as we
used to call it by the state not people
being punished by other criminals for
not fitting in with them which is what
you get and that you you would have to
have and this of course reflects Society
outside you would have to have a total
exclusion of drugs but it's very hard to
exclude drugs from prison when society
makes soal effort to exclude them from
itself free people can take drugs it's
not surprising that prisoners are taking
them this is actually my last question
to you Peter did it give you more or
less faith in the rehabilitation system
after prison given that you were in
there with ex-convicts these are people
who had now left prison they were back
in there presumably they were asked by
Channel 4 to take on the role of like
prisoners so that they could have the
simulation but in terms of the
conversations you were having the
interactions how did it fure your how
did it change your views about
Rehabilitation Rehabilitation like
addiction doesn't exist there is no such
thing nor any record of ever having
happened you don't think people can
rehabilitate people grow up and mature
and tire of crime or they get or they
they cease to be able to run fast enough
to get away after they've committed it
but I'm not an indic Cas in favor of
trying to change people's characters the
idea of Rehabilitation of working on
someone to make him a different person
seems to me to be totalitarian in a free
Society you punish people for wrong acts
uh and make it plain to them that if
they do them again they'll be punished
again and you also make it plain to
other people that if they do these wrong
acts they too will be punished that's
how free Society treats the the people
in it who inevitably
transgress I the whole idea of reation
is repulsive to me and I I wouldn't be
in favor of it if I believe it happened
but no I don't it doesn't change my view
on that at all can an individual choose
to rehabilitate themselves
well I say what do you mean by the word
individuals can choose to stop doing bad
things and often
do uh but they do that for many reasons
they learn for instance that it's
disastrous for their family life they
learn that it it EST Stranges them from
their children they learn that prison
however strong and tough you are is
never going to be a nice place and they
want to return to it uh they change
their lives while remaining the same
people and that suits me I don't I say I
want people to remain free men and women
I don't want but that's the catch it
sounds like broken it sounds like you're
saying they can change their behavior
but not change their character I guess
I'm just questioning whether or not
perhaps a person could choose to change
their character could CH to change you
have to ask somebody else it's not
something I anything about fair enough I
seem to have been stuck with the same
character all my life Peter thanks for
joining
[Music]
me